custom file feed ten years ago and today
it was in ruins now it's all [ __ ] and
span what happened
a big foreign investor got involved
Castel file fee is a hamlet in Tuscany a
ghost town since the 1970s it's been
bought for 250 million euros and is now
getting a comprehensive facelift
complete with a new Main Street two
luxury hotels four pools a golf course
and a tennis court the mastermind behind
the project is Stefano house the resorts
manager old farm houses are also being
restored a 240 square metre home here
will go for about a million euros
landscape gardeners and architects are
aiming for maximum authenticity
restoring as much original detail as
possible
felis was for Indian Idol we're trying
to retain as much as we can find in
these ruins we clean it up take a look
at the roof we take the roof off the
ruin clean the individual shingles
number them and then reposition them on
the renovated house that retains the
character of the building the way it was
a hundred years ago we do our best to
avoid using new materials when we make
repairs this villa looks modest from the
outside inside the look is traditional
Tuscan and luxurious the American owners
opted to buy here in castelló fee rather
than on the popular Amalfi Coast we came
here and we fell in love it was love at
first sight and we love the neighborhood
we love the product we love everything
that goes on around the area but most of
all we love the people because they're
very warm and inviting and approachable
here you know you get a chicken dish in
rosemary you know which is very good for
416 euro
but Castel Fifi still doesn't feel like
a real Italian village though it's
geared to tourists there aren't many
tourists here even though all but one of
the new homes have been sold
is it because Castel Fluffy's been
turned into a sort of Tuscan Disneyland
Disneyland it's not like we've built an
amusement park there aren't any bouncy
castles here everything you see here has
been built in keeping with local
stipulations and with local materials it
fits the description of an Italian
village the village was bought by the
German tourism group tui it's investing
millions and says it's become the
largest employer in the area the tourism
giant has created 200 jobs in the
building trade gastronomy and hotels
analyzer ed Jeannie has worked at the
resort since it opened she says it's
been a positive development for her and
for the area I live in a village here
close by and for a for me it was a great
job opportunity
if you think that Custer Falls anyway
was a sort of lost and the ghost village
because anyway when all the inhabitants
are left the restoration there of
custard pallfy is something that also
the local people appreciated Monte Oni
is a real living village nine kilometers
to the east the people here also depend
on tourism in the last few years
business has fallen off because of the
economic crisis fewer Italian holiday
makers are coming to stay many companies
in Italy are struggling banks are still
burdened with piles of bad debt
the villagers hope Castel Philippi will
draw prosperous people to the area and
to Monte Oney Cristina capellini says
business in her shop has been picking up
it's a very positive development for
both custom fo fee and Monte only we are
benefitting here as well many guests do
makers as far as monta oniy we stay by
our wine and food we have lots of
customers now in Castel file fee
analyzer a genie shows us one of the
hotel suites they cost up to 400 euros a
night
guests are even assigned a member of
staff whose job it is to look after them
personally
the genie doesn't see any downside to to
his presence here she views it as an
opportunity the region will benefit of
this type of project and maybe if in the
future there will be more project like
this one it could be just a sort of a
new start for the Tuscany because if you
consider that the industry the the
problem of the industry is that they had
in this period for sure the tourism
could be just a new field to be explored
much much more and more all that's
missing are lots of guests the resort
isn't exactly buzzing yet and that
includes the new 5-star hotel a lot of
foreign money has been spent on making
Castel file fee beautiful but this kind
of project will not really do much to
revive Italy's still flagging economy
you